it's different for you you know it is I
don't own this type of fabric I never
wear red but I felt like tonight was the
night what a year man for you women and
music this is such a cool event every
year the biggest stars what does it mean
to you to be here um it's emotional I I
don't feel like I belong
rising star but I'm rising and so it's
really wonderful to get to just share
the room with such incredibly talented
beautiful women and music you're already
getting an award tonight so the awards
are on lock for this week but the Grammy
nominations are tomorrow have you
thought about what it would mean not to
figure out are you gonna be able to
sleep tonight it happens great if it
doesn't that I'm gonna work even harder
on my next album but honestly being here
tonight is like the biggest win of all
and this whole year just having people
listen to my music and being open to
listening to my music it's like the best
nomination ever a very big moment with
Taylor Swift how did that come to be
it's really really cool thanks dad
that's the ultimate when she gives you
the seal of approval you're like I've
made it she she's so kind and she wanted
to she wanted to go to the show and was
like let's do a song together and I was
like oh me okay but we have so much fun
together and what really connects she
works really hard and I'm working really
hard and I think that she sees that I
don't know what she sees but I'm happy
that we're friends and she's so
supportive of us keeping an extra
nervous yeah I'd do it now you've been
through the wringer now you know this I
think from me I get nervous
new experiences like this is very new
for me being not going to an event but
being a part of an event having to give
a speech like it's very nerve-wracking
how did you prepare and what are you
gonna say because this is every single
powerful woman in the music business is
here tonight thank you so much for
reminding you're not nervous goodbye
I don't know what I'm gonna say but
we'll find out congratulations thank you
[Music]
[Applause]